ja schönen guten Morgen meine Damen und
Herren Dritter Tag der Haushaltsdebatte
und heute geht es gleich am Anfang um
den größten einzeletat Arbeit und
Soziales
166,2 Milliarden Euro hat Hubertus Heil
zur Verfügung und darin ist auch das
Bürgergeld und wir haben es ja schon
eben in den Berichten gesehen gestern
Abend hat sich der vermietungsausschuss
geeinigt und damit wird das Bürgergeld
Morgen ohne Beratung im Bundestag und im
Bundesrat verabschiedet werden können
und zum ersten Januar in Kraft treten
können daran ist kein Zweifel mehr es
sollte das Meisterstück von Hubertus
Heil werden das Bürgergeld was ist davon
übrig nach dem Kompromiss darüber möchte
ich jetzt reden mit meinen beiden Gästen
nicht begrüße Irene mich halitsch sie
sind Mitglied in diesem
Vermittlungsausschuss und erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Bündnis grün und Stefan Müller ebenfalls
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
Union aber auch Mitglied im Ausschuss in
diesem Vermittlungsausschuss über den
wir ganz kurz reden wollen Frau
mechanisches kam glaube ich um 20 25
über die Agenturen Einigung das war doch
gestern Abend nur noch proforma oder wir
haben schon natürlich ausführlich noch
mal über den Vorschlag des
Arbeitsministeriums beraten und haben
dann am Ende des verhandlungsausschusses
halt eben diese Einigung gefunden die
wirklich also die Geschichte oder das
Ende der Geschichte von Hartz IV also
will ich es mal ausdrücken wirklich
markiert und ich bin wirklich froh dass
wir am Ende dieser langen Beratung auch
wirklich zu einem guten Kompromiss
gekommen sind die Union so sehen ist
viele Kommentatoren hat viel rein
verhandeln können Herr Müller sind sie
denn rund um zufrieden das ist ein gutes
Ergebnis dass wir da gestern gefunden
haben es bleibt bei dem bewährten
Prinzip fördern und fördern das heißt es
wird auch weiterhin Mitwirkungen
erwartet das sind Sanktionsmöglichkeiten
auch weiterhin möglich und es kommt eben
nicht zu einer Rückabwicklung der
erfolgreichen Arbeitsmarktreformen die
wir vor vielen Jahren gemeinsam als
Union mit rot grün geschlossen haben und
es wird auch keinen Einstieg ins
bedingungslose Grundeinkommen geben so
wie es eben auch ursprünglich geplant
war Frau Engelmeier Vorsitzende des
Sozialverbandes sagt die Streichung der
vertrauenszeit damit sei das Herzstück
dieser Reform genommen teilen Sie diese
Meinung ich würde eher sagen dass das
Herzstück der Reformen weitgehend
erhalten geblieben ist der das Herzstück
der Reform ist ja dass Menschen eben
nicht mehr in jede x-billige Arbeit
sozusagen gezwungen werden ja also dass
dieser sogenannte vermittlungsvorgang
fällt im hartz4-system ist es ja so dass
Menschen also wirklich jede Arbeit
annehmen mussten einfach nur damit sie
irgendeine Beschäftigung haben das fällt
weg sondern es steht jetzt im Vorgang
dass wir die Menschen weiter
qualifizieren dass wir sie weiterbilden
und eben auch nachhaltig eben in
Beschäftigung bringen damit dieser
dritte Effekt und diese ewige Spirale
zwischen Beschäftigung und Jobcenter
endlich aufgelöst wird und das ist
wirklich das Kernelement auch ja das
bürgergeldansatzes Menschen eben weiter
zu qualifizieren und eben nicht in jede
x-beliebige Beschäftigung zu zwingen und
das ist ein wichtiges Kernelement was
wir erhalten konnten Friedrich Merz hat
vor der Einigung noch am Wochenende
gesagt also es kommt darauf an für uns
dass Menschen schnell wieder in den
Arbeitsmarkt integriert werden Frau
mechalitsch hat gerade angesprochen
dieses weiter fördern und weiter bilden
steht jetzt mehr im Mittelpunkt als die
schnelle Arbeitsvermittlung das
widerspricht sich ja eigentlich aber
wenn man die Reform wenn man sich Hartz
IV anguckt in den letzten Jahren war es
ja oft so die Leute gegen ihn holten
sich in Stempel ab und waren dann nach
einer Woche wieder beim Arbeitsamt so
ungefähr zumindest umso wichtiger ist es
ja dass auch es weiterhin
Mitwirkungsmöglichkeiten gibt und das
für den Fall dass eben Mitwirkung
verweigert wird auch eine Möglichkeit
besteht zu sanktionieren da kommt im
übrigen gar nicht auf die Zahl derer an
die bisher schon von Sanktionen
betroffen waren sondern die
zuständigen Behörden die Ämter brauchen
dieses Instrument das im übrigen auch
die Rückmeldung die wir ja gerade von
dem Praktikern von vor Ort bekommen dass
sie ohne dieses Instrument jedenfalls
einiges an Handlungsmöglichkeiten gerade
nicht haben niemand wird widersprechen
und es war auch nie Teil unserer Kritik
dass es auch um Weiterbildung gehen muss
natürlich muss es Weiterbildung geben
und es ist ohne Zweifel richtiger und
wichtiger als es vielleicht zu dem
Zeitpunkt war wie wir ihr Hartz
IV-Reformen gemeinsam beschlossen haben
und wie wir über Massenarbeitslosigkeit
geredet haben aber ich wiederhole noch
mal das war nie Ansatz unserer Kritik
ich finde richtig dass wir das tun das
ist auch um Weiterbildung geht es muss
aber auch darum gehen dass dann wenn es
um eine Arbeitsvermittlung geht dann
eben auch die Möglichkeit sozusagen
geben muss dann da auch entsprechende
Vorschläge zu machen Angebote zu machen
und die dann auch angenommen werden
müssen übrigens fast allerdings leider
nicht ganz zusammen wenn jetzt die Ampel
sagt es geht hier um Weiterbildung der
stellen wir in den Fokus gleichzeitig
aber in dem Haus seitdem wir gleich
beraten werden die Mittel für den
Eingliederungstitel aus dem diese Weite
Bildung bezahlt wird um 400 Millionen
gekürzt wird okay die Frage hätte ich
auch gestellt das ist unlogisch 400.000
sind weniger eingestellt worden gerade
in einer Reform die ja Wert legt auf die
Weiterbildung und wenn man sieht das
ungefähr zwei Drittel der Menschen die
sich bei den Jobcentern melden
eigentlich keine Ausbildung haben dann
scheint es ja auch notwendig diese
Menschen vorzubilden aber dann brauchen
wir auch das Geld dafür oder nicht
natürlich ist es absolut notwendig dass
man diese Menschen fortbildet dass man
sie weiterqualifiziert um sie eben auch
in nachhaltige Beschäftigung zu bringen
das wichtige beim Bürgergeld ist aber
auf jeden Fall dass wir diesen
Paradigmenwechsel auch in den Jobcentern
haben dass wir wirklich eine Beratung
auch auf Augenhöhe ermöglichen dass
wirklich also die Betroffenen und auch
die Jobcenter eine
Kooperationsvereinbarung miteinander
abschließen die wirklich individuelle
Schau individuell schaut welche
Maßnahmen sind eigentlich im konkreten
Einzelfall erforderlich um Menschen
wirklich nachhaltig wieder in
beschäftigen zu bringen und das ist
sozusagen auch der Einstieg in den
Systemwechsel wenn wir wegkommen wollen
von Hartz IV hin zu einem nachhaltigen
Bürgergeld und das ist wichtig und dabei
ist es auch wichtig dass eben nicht
sozusagen bei der ersten Ansprache durch
das Jobcenter beim ersten Brief den die
Menschen bekommen gleich zwei Seiten
sanktions Androhungen dabei sind auch
das fällt weg ja also auch da wird
sozusagen den Menschen viel mehr auf
Augenhöhe mit Meer Respekt eben auch
begegnet damit eben auch tatsächlich die
Menschen auch in die Lage versetzt
werden sich um eine Arbeitsaufnahme zu
kümmern und sich nicht erst mal Gedanken
darum machen zu müssen okay was droht
mir eigentlich wenn ich jetzt dieses
oder jenes vielleicht nicht
hundertprozentig einhalte also die
Menschen werden wirklich auch in die
Lage versetzt sich darauf zu
konzentrieren wieder nachhaltig in
Beschäftigung zu kommen und eben auch
Weiterbildungsangebote
Qualifizierungsmaßnahmen anzunehmen und
auch wirklich nachhaltig davon zu
profitieren da muss ich noch mal
nachfragen Müller das der
kooperationsplan den jeder einzelne
Arbeitslose kriegt mit seinem Job
Berater der sieht aber doch wenn ich ähm
Hermann Gröhe gestern verstanden habe
vor dass eine Rechtsbelehrung in schon
beim ersten Tag stattfinden wird oder so
interpretiere ich das in der Tat auch
übrigens diese Kooperationsvereinbarung
die gibt es ja heute schon also wir
haben ja heute schon die Situation dass
wenn ein Mensch von einem Arbeitnehmer
ein Arbeitsloser Mensch dann hat sie
tatsächlich in den all die zwei Bezug
fällt nachdem immer dann
Arbeitslosengeld 1 bekommen hat heute ja
auch schon mit seinem zuständigen
Sachbearbeiter Sachbearbeiterin als
solche Kooperationsvereinbarung
anschließt und jedenfalls nach den
Gesprächen die ich geführt habe auch
gerade in den letzten Wochen ist es
heute in auch schon so dass er eine
solche Vereinbarung gemacht wird dass
auch darüber geredet wird wo kann es
Weiterbildung geben das aber ja in der
Tat auch darauf hingewiesen wird dass
man von der betroffenen Person auch
erwartet dass sie da entsprechend
mitwirkt und diese
Mitwirkungsmöglichkeiten auch verbunden
damit zu sagen was passiert wenn du
nicht mitwirkst die wären dann eben weg
gewesen und insofern sage ich ist es ein
gutes Ergebnis es bleibt bei dieser
Kooperationsvereinbarung es bleibt beim
Angebot auch von Weiterbildung dort wo
es Sinn macht bzw auch mit Angeboten die
Sinn macht das ist ja auch Sinn machen
wir auch entscheidend und trotzdem
bleibt es auch dabei dass man sagen kann
wir warten von dir aber auch dass du
mitwirkst Hartz IV 2005 beschlossen dann
endgültig fand ja zu einer Zeit statt da
gab es über 5 Millionen Arbeitslose in
Deutschland heute ist das ganz anders es
müsste doch eigentlich für jemand der
arbeitslos wird und den Jobcenter geht
relativ einfach sein
einen der vielen freien Jobs zu finden
der ungefähr auch seinen Möglichkeiten
entspricht
ja das ist eben leider nicht so einfach
also ich selber komme aus einer Stadt
ich glaube mit der höchsten SGB ii-quote
im ganzen Land ja also mit dem mit den
Menschen also wo die meisten Menschen
also wirklich also auch ein Hartz IV
Bezug haben die eben erwerbslos sind und
da sieht man einfach auch was das
lebenspraktisch einfach bedeutet unter
welchen Umständen halt eben auch
Menschen wenn sie ihre Arbeit verlieren
dann wirklich auch vielleicht auch
Vermittlungshemmnisse haben eben weil
vielleicht die nötige Qualifikation
nicht vorliegt einfach weil vielleicht
Weiterbildung noch nicht in Anspruch
genommen werden konnte und deswegen sind
ja eben diese Kernelemente auch so
wahnsinnig wichtig also wenn es so
einfach wäre zu sagen okay wir haben ja
auf der Seite viele erwerbslos und auf
der anderen Seite viele offene Stellen
und dann vermitteln wie mal eben so eins
zu eins oder dann dann bräuchten wir
diese Arbeitsmarktreform mir auch nicht
wo eben auch Weiterbildungen Vordergrund
steht also das heißt dass das erhalten
geblieben ist das ist wirklich
wahnsinnig wichtig und vor allen Dingen
dass die Menschen auch wirklich in die
Lage versetzt werden sich um die
Jobsuche zu kümmern und zum Beispiel bei
dem erhalte Schonvermögens eben nicht
darüber nach zeigen müssen ob sie morgen
umziehen müssen oder ob sie erstmal ihre
Altersvorsorge aufgeben müssen auch das
hat ja etwas mit Respekt und noch
Vertrauen in die Menschen zu tun und
dass wir diese Kernelemente erhalten
konnten ist wirklich sehr sehr wichtig
und damit muss ich noch mal sagen Hartz
IV ist Geschichte schon Vermögen ist ein
wichtiges Stichwort da hat er die FDP
vor allem darauf hingearbeitet dass man
zum Beispiel Altersversorgung behalten
darf das gilt für kleine Unternehmer die
sich was zur Seite gelegt haben das ist
mir noch nicht so ganz klar geworden
denn die Staffelung auf 40.000 für den
ersten 15 für die weiteren Person im
Haushalt die sind allen Teilen bekannt
aber darüber hinaus habe ich zumindest
ein Vogel von der FDP verstanden gibt es
gerade für diese Personengruppe noch die
Chance geben diese Alterssicherung
erstmal zu retten für ein Jahr und was
der Vogel meint müssen Sie natürlich
selber fragen ich kann sagen und so war
das ein wichtiger Punkt ganz einfach
weil in der jetzigen Zeit nicht
vermittelbar ist dass diejenigen die
keine Beschäftigung haben tatsächlich
ist sehr viel von ihrem Vermögen nicht
aufbrauchen müssen werden wir
gleichzeitig erleben dass viele
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
diesem Land angesichts der steigenden
Preise dann eben ja gerade auch ihr
Vermögen aufbrauchen und übrigens erst
recht auch Handwerker wir alle sind doch
gerade viel unterwegs reden zum Beispiel
mit dem Bäckern die er da vor einigen
Wochen auch besonders im Fokus standen
die mir mitteilen sie brauchen ja gerade
jetzt wo sie eben auch von diesem Preis
steigen betroffen sind vieles von ihrem
Vermögen auf das für die
Altersversorgung gedacht war und
insofern hätte das was vorgeschlagen war
definitiv einen falschen Anreiz gesetzt
auch ein falsches Signal was die Frage
dessen angeht was kann man jemand
leisten und muss sich Leistung auch
wieder lohnen und muss sich auch lohnen
dass man für sein Alter etwas
zurücklegen die Menschen besser
qualifizieren bedeutet eigentlich auch
länger im Jobcenter sich aufzuhalten
auch häufiger zu kommen schätzungsweise
jedenfalls sind die Mitarbeiter im
Jobcenter eigentlich jetzt schon völlig
ausgelastet wie viele neue stellen
wollen Sie denn einrichten und wie soll
das Problem gelöst werden es ist
natürlich wichtig dass die Jobcenter gut
ausgestattet sind deswegen was uns ja
auch so wichtig dass das Bürgergeld
schnell in Kraft treten kann also dass
wir jetzt wirklich diese Reform zum 1
Januar ja also auch tatsächlich
einführen können eben um auch den
Jobcentern die Möglichkeit zu geben sich
da entsprechend aufzustellen und halt
eben auch das Personal dafür vorzuhalten
diese Qualifizierungsmaßnahmen auch
diese vielen Gespräche zu führen das ist
selbstverständlich wichtig und deswegen
bin ich ja auch so froh dass jetzt
dieser Kompromiss gelungen ist der
natürlich ein paar Dinge enthält mit
denen wir die wir uns anders gewünscht
hätten ja so ehrlich muss man natürlich
sein aber ich glaube so ist es halt eben
am Ende der Union auch gegangen jetzt
haben sich beide Seiten aufeinander zu
bewegt und wir haben ein gutes
einigungspaket geschnürt und wenn jetzt
der Deutsche Bundestag zustimmt und der
Bundesrat auch und das Bürgergeld in
Kraft treten kann wenn ich mir sicher
sind wir insgesamt auf einem guten Weg
Hubertus Heil war gestern als letzte
Redner der für die Presse gegen quasi
anzumerken wie früher ist dass er der
Minister sein wird dir dieses ungeliebte
Hartz IV beiseite schieben wird er hat
aber auch etwas gesagt was für schon von
Andrea Nahles und auch von den
Mitarbeitern der Jobcenter gehört haben
zum ersten Januar ist diese Reform eben
nicht umzusetzen dass das Geld also die
Steigerung ja für die einzelnen Menschen
aber die weiteren Reformschritte völlig
unmöglich in der jetzigen Verfasstheit
der Jobcenter auch übrigens mit den
Personal was dazu Verfügung steht was
hat er denn dazu im Ausschuss gesagt
tatsächlich war das der vom kein Thema
was jedenfalls die Frage angeht wie es
dann konkret vor Ort umgesetzt werden
soll das ist ja auch etwas was im
übrigen wieder wir im Bundestag noch
auch des Ministerium mit am Ende machen
kann sondern es kommt darauf an wie
läuft es jetzt in der Bundesagentur wie
läuft's in den Jobcentern vor Ort oder
eben bei den Kommunen es gibt ja auch
eine ganze Reihe von Kommunen die diesen
eigenen Zuständigkeit machen die
früheren options Kommunen also insofern
wird man mal abwarten ich fand es
jedenfalls auch sehr bemerkenswert weil
es so in der Diskussion jedenfalls nach
meinem Gefühl sind nicht stattgefunden
hatte und nicht diskutiert worden ist
aber entscheidend ist ja am Ende dass es
dann auch tatsächlich funktioniert und
ob es dann tatsächlich zum ersten Januar
ist oder zum ersten März ist
ehrlicherweise für mich jetzt nicht ganz
so relevant wir wollen dass es
funktioniert das ist richtig und wir
wollen dort anknüpfen wo wir vor vielen
Jahren auch gemeinsam diese
Arbeitsmarktreformen auch beraten und
beschlossen haben es waren die
erfolgreichsten Arbeitsmarktreformen und
die wollten wir nicht zurück für die
Arbeitslosen die Arbeit suchen dann ist
das sehr relevant das funktioniert auch
das nur dann aber auch für die Jobcenter
Mitarbeiter ich muss noch mal darauf
zurückkommen es soll ein Wohngeld
eingeführt werden dass wir die auch
belasten und zum Beispiel die Ukrainer
die ja nun massenweise und
schätzungsweise in den kommenden Wochen
und Monaten ich will sich herbei reden
noch mehr nach Deutschland kommen müssen
und wollen die landen alle gleich beim
Jobcenter also noch mal die Frage diese
Reform ist sehr ehrgeizig wird die
ausgeführt auf dem Rücken der
Mitarbeiter der Jobcenter natürlich
nicht also selbstverständlich ist die
Reform ehrgeizig und sie haben die
Probleme angesprochen mit denen nicht
nur die Jobcenter sondern auch die
Kommunen konfrontiert sind und deswegen
ist es natürlich unsere Aufgabe die
Reform so auszugestalten dass sie am
Ende auch ihre Wirkung entfalten kann
und eben nicht auf dem Rücken ja der
Beschäftigten in den Einrichtungen
ausgetragen wird und deswegen wird es
dort natürlich auch zu Veränderungen
kommen müssen noch wie ein Müller vorhin
noch zutreffen gesagt hat auch die
Arbeitsagentur wird sich natürlich da
Gedanken machen müssen wie sie diese
Reform am besten umsetzt mir ist wichtig
dass das Gesetz wirklich jetzt am ersten
Januar in Kraft treten kann eben damit
auch die Reformschritte die ja
alternative dann eintreten sollen auch
sorgfältig vorbereitet werden können
auch darum geht es ja wenn wir jetzt mit
der Gesetzgebung Verzögerungen gehabt
hätten hätte sich alles nach hinten
verschoben davon hätten die Menschen
nichts gehabt davon hätten aber auch die
Jobcenter nicht gehabt oder noch die
Kommunen nicht oder die anderen
Einrichtungen und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir auch hier im Zeitplan
geblieben sind wir reden über das
Bürgergeld weil es in den Etat des
bundesarbeitsministers fällt und dessen
Gesetzentwurf ist verabschiedet wird das
morgen hier ohne Diskussion das ist
sicherlich nur noch Formsache wie ist es
im Bundesrat sehen sie da noch Probleme
oder wird das so durchgehen ich will
keine Probleme es waren ja gestern alle
Bundesländer auch vertreten des
Abstimmungsergebnis war eindeutig wir
hatten eine Reihe von auch Ablehnungen
aber was jedenfalls die Bundesländer
angeht war da ebenfalls die Auffassung
fast einhellig das auch das dazugestimmt
wird und ich gehe davon aus dass sich
das Abstimmungsverhalten gestern Abend
im Vermittlungsausschuss nicht von dem
unterscheidet was morgen im Bundesrat
passiert wenn die Ablehnung kam von der
AFD die wollen mit einer Einstellung
sicherlich interessanter die Linke aber
Frau mechanic das Ding ist jetzt durch
oder ja da gab es einen Enthaltung und
darüber sind wir auch froh dass es also
mit einer breiten Mehrheit jetzt
getragen wurde oder dass dieser
Kompromiss eben auch mit einer breiten
Mehrheit
Vermittlungsausschuss getragen wurde
deswegen bin ich sehr zuversichtlich für
die Abstimmung am Freitag im Bundestag
und auch im Bundesrat und ja damit kann
es endlich losgehen am besten nur
apropos losgehen drinnen geht's jetzt
los vielen dank vielen Dank Herr Müller
und ich gebe bereit